I'm very excited to speak with you Lenny
is one of my favorite characters on this
show and you play him so well
um I've seen all of these episodes
except for the final episode and I can
say
um you are not in the season enough and
I was sad to see that but just jumping
into Lenny's character can you talk a
little bit about where Lenny's head is
at at the in this season and how he's
coping with what happened with him and
Midge I mean I think you know Lenny has
gotten deeper into his life of
litigation which is a reflection of you
know what happened to the real Lenny
Bruce
you know
um
it's a heavy burden and I think at the
same time as that he's exploring ways to
you know help um
you know mask or heal some of that pain
that he's enduring because of it and
because of obviously other things and so
he's probably getting a little bit
deeper into his addictions you know
um
and in some ways it's it's it's those
things have just started to he's become
so sort of subsumed under them that
you know
to see Midge as such a always has always
been such a
a moment of levity for him
you know she always kind of I my sense
of over the course of this show it's
you know he sees The Light Within her
and that's really all he's reflecting
back
and they kind of are able to bounce that
back and forth and have that beautiful
simpatic codes
you know so lovely
but I think when they encounter each
other at the airport that you know
there's a sort of a sign that
you know his his ability to reflect back
is just not
you know it's just a little muted by
another degree of exhaustion that that
he's having to contend with yeah I mean
is there an aspect of Lenny Bruce's life
that you wish you could have if there
was more time there's something that you
would have uh explored there are yeah I
mean there's a lot there's a a number of
you know in terms of his mythology you
know of course there's a lot of his
performances that that that were um
fascinating and that we're met with uh
you know controversy
uh
there's a couple that are really
interesting to me you know one that ha
you know that happened in London England
uh there's an amazing performance that
he did in Australia that I just you know
I think Lenny in the outback would have
been a great
um
bottle episode
as they call it I think that's what
we don't know anything over here
um but uh but yeah no there's plenty for
sure no it's it it it it it's it's just
been a kind of a a joy and privilege to
get to explore him in any capacity but
I'm endlessly fascinated by that man for
sure and he's become very kind of dear
to me yeah I mean that I'm not gonna
give up anytime soon
I mean I I think a lot of people like
this series and a lot of people enjoy
the relationship that Lenny and Midge
have together between these two
characters was that surprising to you to
see that reaction and do you why do you
think people are so attracted to that
relationship it was surprising because
you know coming into the show I really
just thought I was doing the pilot and
you know I was very smitten with the
pilot
for what it was but I didn't think that
it was going to invite
him back you know I thought Oh They'll
you know maybe each episode will have
some historical figure that they will
touch upon
but
uh
but being invited invited back was just
like
just so juicy and wonderful I mean you
know it was fantastic to get to play in
this make-believe you know it's a really
fun show to be a part of
and uh
and in terms of why people like it I
I mean my sense of it is I mean
hopefully it's for the same reason that
I like Lenny and Midge together they you
know they're just
you know it's just it's like um
it's just the way friends are when you
see two friends get together
[Music]
you know
but that right combination can just be
you can you know you feel like you can
see like light pouring out of people
sometimes when they connect and it's
just a beautiful thing yeah I'm happy
that that worked for Midge and Lenny you
know I don't know it is it's you guys
have great on-screen chemistry so I
think that's what makes it so addictive
um you guys have had a great run with
this series I mean it's it with it being
over is there a specific aspect of this
show that you'll be missing the most I
mean I you know I I really adore
everybody on on board you know
especially our cast it's you know it's
just been a really
fun gang to get to know over the years
and I had this kind of really
Plum position of getting to pop in you
know
a few days a month here and there and
say Hi and then leave again for a nice
long nap
you know and and
that that the rhythm of that was really
nice also just shooting you know in New
York City and
at the studio we were at where I was
able to just you know ride my bike to
work or just the all of those things
were just so
just really Charmed it just has been
so Charmed and so I
I guess I'll miss all of it but but most
of all just getting to see the gang you
know be together and
you know they they are the ones that put
in
all the work you know I kind of just got
to
come by and lick it once in a while and
you know do a little dance so i i yeah
I'm just really grateful for for them
and I'll miss them and speaking about
that cast I mean is there somebody
specific on that series that you didn't
have a scene with that you wish you
could have you know I would have loved
to have done
something with uh Joel
I adore Michael ziegan and
he's been a good pal over the years and
so I you know
we could have lobbed some balls at each
other or something I don't know I think
it would have been an interesting
dynamic between the two of you guys yeah
I'm sure they would have found their way
and just um well just looking at the end
of this series uh because I don't know
what's gonna happen and I'm curious on
what you can tease for the end of
Lenny's story in this show and whether
he'll find any sort of closure with
Midge or if we're gonna see any of that
kind of stuff I mean my lips are sealed
as is what I've been told to say
uh
uh yeah I think
can I tease you'll see something that's
you know what I respect that I I respect
that a lot I understand there's a lot
that you can't give away
um and then just you know
being a part of a show like this there's
always I feel like especially a longer
running show do you have a big takeaway
from or a lesson that you learned from
filming uh maisel I mean just you know
you know stay hydrated
and you know plan your day accordingly
you know get in as many naps as you can
and uh
you know come prepared I mean yeah
that's I think those are lessons for
life in general
um well I really want to thank you for
speaking with me I I like I love this
show love seeing you on it I love
whenever you appear also as like a guest
star in other shows like The Company You
Keep which I was surprised there you go
oh fantastic